the ADL told a counterterrorism agency
to investigate journalists and political
commentators because we are saying
things they don't like they are TR
trying explicitly to use the arm of the
law to silence us at gunpoint now they
don't even claim that we violated any
law right they're not claiming that
because we we haven't the daily signal
reached out to the Washington State uh
State Patrol about this and they're one
of the state agencies that participated
in this Fusion Center they indicated
that they take emails from the ADL and
various other interest groups under
advisement but they denied opening any
investigation on the basis of the adl's
email so according to them as far as we
know there is not a current criminal
investigation against say me for
tweeting things that they don't like now
obviously we have no idea whether that's
true or not